For more than a hundred thousand years, humanity
has buried their dead. We commit the bodies
of our deceased to the ground, earth to earth,
ashes to ashes, dust to dust, in the hope
that one day our dearly departed might get
to enjoy some form of eternal life. But eternal
life might be less appealing than it sounds.
Perhaps there’s a reason that humans bury
their dead… maybe it’s so that the dead
stay buried. And luckily, they do… At least,
most of the time.
Accessible only via a cargo elevator, and
not marked on any official Foundation blueprints,
beneath the northwest corner of Overwatch
Command lies SCP-5555. This SCP isn’t a
creature or carnivorous monster, it’s not
a gateway to another dimension or an entity
with the power to rewrite the very fabric
of reality itself. No, SCP-5555 is a mass
grave filled with corpses. A pit of unknown
origin and indeterminable depth, each body
exhumed from within SCP-5555 shows various
anomalous traits. These bodies can be removed
from the mass grave without any incident,
but given the incalculable depth of this vast,
corpse-filled pit, continued excavation of
SCP-5555 would likely only reveal further
bodies, and fewer answers as to how they came
to be buried beneath the Foundation’s Overwatch
Command.
The bodies recovered during the initial excavation
of SCP-5555 vary in their physical attributes
as well as their causes of death, when one
can even be determined. One body appears to
be a man whose age and ethnicity are both
unclear, as is how he died. But his body is
perfectly preserved, showing no signs of decomposition.
Another of the corpses, has its head covered
with a burlap sack and a noose tightened around
its neck. When these are removed they reveal
an identical noose and sack underneath. When
those are removed they reveal another. And
on and on. The cause of death, in this instance,
is at least apparent - strangulation. Suggesting
the deceased was intended to suffer before
their death.
Some of the other bodies removed from the
pit include one belonging to a middle-aged
Alutiiq woman, whose entire skeleton is formed
of ice that doesn’t melt under increased
temperatures, while a different body is a
human male with eighty percent of its organs
surgically replaced with artificial ones,
driven by gears and mechanisms that continue
to tick away long after death. An adolescent
female with dark blue skin has two severed
hands grasping its throat, while a Caucasian
woman was found with both of her eyes gouged
out.
Perhaps most curious of all is the coffin,
crafted from black stone, that cannot be opened.
All attempts to open it have been resisted
by some form of internal force keeping the
coffin shut. While it’s unable to be opened,
it is believed to contain a human inside.
A coffin with a person inside of it. Those
familiar with the objects contained by the
Foundation may make a connection to SCP-076,
Able, a humanoid entity also contained inside
a coffin. A curious connection too. As you’ll
come to see, when dealing with SCP-5555, the
appearance of many familiar faces may be more
than just vague connections.
None of these corpses, or their various anomalous
properties, answer any of the pressing questions
about SCP-5555’s exact nature and origin.
In fact, the bodies found within the grave
only raise new questions about this seemingly
bottomless pit that the Foundation was either
built over, or knowingly hides beneath its
lowest depths.
The truth behind SCP-5555 is shrouded in mystery,
unanswered questions piled on top of each
other like the bodies in the mass grave itself,
a pile that stacks all the way up to the highest
levels of the Foundation’s own administration.
In actuality, the bodies buried in SCP-5555
are part of a vast and insidious game, played
by the heads of a number of GOIs, or Groups
of Interest, as well as the SCP Foundation’s
very own Administrator. But how do the corpses
of these anomalous beings factor into the
aforementioned game, and what is its ultimate
outcome? Examining the file describing SCP-5555,
albeit with adequate O5 security clearance,
answers some of those burning questions about
the mystery at play.
Dr. Everett Mann, the current O5-1, was the
first to uncover the existence of SCP-5555
and the corpses contained within it. Mann
created a series of notes detailing his findings,
intended for his successor. In these, Mann
claimed that the Administrator, one Francis
Fritzwilliams, the only figure with authority
above that of the O5 Council, blackballed
him - meaning Fritzwilliams had voted against
allowing Dr. Mann to remain a member of the
SCP Foundation.
Everett Mann had believed the Administrator
to be his friend, so naturally it came as
a surprise when ‘Fritz’ framed him for
an elaborate plot to eliminate Mann’s fellow
Overseer Council members. Based on information
from his own O5-1 predecessor, Mann believed
whoever took up the role after he was voted
out would have to take up the role of killing
Fritz for the good of the Foundation. But
what connection between Fritz and a pit full
of anomalous corpses could possibly warrant
Mann urging his successor to eliminate the
Foundation’s Administrator?
Dr Mann’s notes to his successor continue
with detailed instructions as to how they
would go about killing Fritz, and that firstly,
they would require a lair. Mann himself was
holed up in an isolated Arctic shack for three
decades after being blackballed by the Administrator,
before Fritz sent his own private death squad
after the former Overseer. Mann stressed the
importance of having a defensible, isolated
location, stocked with armed guards and traps
for his successor to lie in wait for Fritz.
It was because of the traps Mann had set in
his shack that he was able to escape Fritz’s
death squad with his life.
Secondly, Mann urges his new O5-1 successor
to always have several escape plans in place,
and to be prepared to leave the lair, or indeed
any other location, at any time. Dr. Mann
also suggested telling falsified escape plans
to close friends, in case Fritz got to them
first, or finding an SCP that allows the new
O5-1 to teleport to safety. Third, Mann suggests
the need for multiple, fully-stocked safehouses.
After all, escape plans are entirely pointless
unless you’ve got somewhere secure to actually
escape to.
Everett Mann also suggested, much like his
advice with escape plans, to have fake safehouses
or SCP anomalies on-hand to get you to the
real ones. How does one obtain access to an
SCP? According to Mann, placing moles or blackmailing
personnel within every Foundation facility
is one way, as doing so granted him access
to SCP-268, a hat that makes its wearer practically
invisible, which came in handy during his
escape.
Of course, installing your own trusted moles
is a potentially tricky feat to accomplish,
given that Fritz has the entire Foundation,
and many other Groups of Interest in his thrall.
But if anyone has the power to do so, and
by extension the power to bring Fitz down,
it would be another Overseer.
Of course, Mann’s plot to eliminate Fritz
and highly-detailed words of warning to his
successor do little to explain the pit full
of anomalous corpses. Contained within the
file for SCP-5555 is an email to the Foundation’s
Administrator from the CEO of Wondertainment,
an anomalous toy manufacturer and one of a
number of Groups of Interest to the Foundation.
In it, the CEO congratulates Fritz on an excellent
win, and asks for a copy of an unknown file,
as well as mentioning the leaders of other
Groups of Interest such as the Church of the
Broken God. According to the email, this unidentified
file was to be sent physically as opposed
to electronically, giving Dr Mann his next
lead in uncovering the mystery of SCP-5555.
Mann traveled to the headquarters of Wondertainment,
‘Wonderworld’, to retrieve the file, using
his special hat to avoid detection. Seems
like an easy enough task, except Wonderworld
is a pocket dimension that slowly transforms
human beings into…something else. Time working
against him, Mann hastily made his way to
Wonder Tower, and attempted to recover the
file that would maybe give him all the answers
to this bizarre, twisted mystery. Unfortunately,
Wondertainment’s CEO, Dr. Holly Wondertainment,
got to him first.
Confronted by Dr. Wondertainment, Everett
Mann demanded to know who was involved in
the scheme, besides her and the Administrator.
He posited that the O5 Council might be somehow
involved, but Dr. Wondertainment claimed that
the game being played was above and beyond
their little ‘numbers club’. Holly proceeded
to point a large, acid-filled Super Soaker
at Mann, and ordered him down onto his knees
when he asked what the purpose of the mass
grave, SCP-5555, was.
Following a fight and the apparent death of
Dr Wondertainment, Mann escaped Wonderworld
with the file, containing an updated version
of the SCP-5555 description and containment
procedures.
The key points featured in this SCP-5555 document
are mentions of sealing the mass grave with
concrete after completing the ‘turnover’
and re-establishing ‘the façade’. It
also mentions that any already-catalogued
SCP entering the pit will die, with its personality,
attributes and any anomalous qualities being
passed on to a new entity, which will appear
close to the location of the initial SCP’s
discovery. So, the pit can not only kill any
SCP that enters it, but can also instantly
recreate them with slight differences and
reposition them. Does this mean the bodies
in SCP-5555 are those of former SCPs? To answer
that, we’ll have to take another look at
the corpses.
Let’s take a look at some of these bodies,
and try to make some connections. We already
discussed the similarities between the coffin
and SCP-076, Able, the entity who also rests
inside a large black coffin. Next, we have
a corpse dressed in yellow, with a burlap
sack covering its head, tightened in place
with a noose. And removing it causes another
sack and another noose to appear under it.
If you ask us, that sounds a lot like SCP-701,
the Hanged King’s Tragedy, which revolves
around a play that heralds the arrival of
a mysterious entity that calls itself the
Hanged King, a being with connections to the
extra-dimensional realm of Alagadda. The Hanged
King entity in SCP-701 revels in decadence
and chaos, so maybe it’s better for it to
be thrown into SCP-5555.
Next, we have the corpse that’s been altered
with mechanical gears. That certainly sounds
familiar too. SCP-217 is a virus that turns
the body into a clockwork being, replacing
organs and tissue with the appearance of gears
and metal. Foundation researchers even noted
the similarity between the body and the appearance
of a corpse fully transformed by SCP-217.
But there’s also the connection to Dr. Charles
Gears, the famed researcher who acts as cold
as ice, and frequently researches anomalies
with connections to the Mekhanite religion
and the Church of the Broken God. It’s been
long rumored that Gears’ body is also altered,
taking on the appearance of clockwork. There’s
no telling what this connection means, but
it’s definitely something to think about.
Next in our retrospective, we have a white
woman whose eyes were gouged out. While this
doesn’t exactly narrow anything down, the
corpse’s secondary anomalous properties
certainly do. Photographs of the body show
a pair of blue eyes that, when viewed through
video, follow the camera. A girl and a camera?
That sounds a lot like SCP-105, the photographer
formerly known as Iris Thompson, who can manipulate
the images in the photographs she takes on
her camera. Iris is typically one of the friendlier,
more approachable anomalies housed by the
Foundation, and seeing her like this is heartbreaking.
So if the corpses in the pit are former SCPs
themselves, and existing objects are reincarnated
and modified after being placed there, how
many times has this happened over the years?
Hidden files display test results involving
numerous ultra-famous anomalies, including
SCP-173, which reappeared in an art exhibit
before it was contained again, but Foundation
researchers were shocked to find that this
time, the statue was made of concrete, giving
it the appearance we all know today. Another
test example involves SCP-049, the Plague
Doctor, who was lured into the pit using a
vial of liquid that he was convinced contained
a vital component to his medical mission.
SCP-049 reappeared in France, this time wearing
the familiar plague doctor mask over his apparent
previous attire, a gas mask.
There had been mentions of some sort of game
being played by the Foundation Administrator
and the heads of various Groups of Interests,
involving a number of anomalies and the killing
and recreation of different SCPs - Many turning
into those that exist within the SCP Archive.
After Dr. Everett Mann’s encounter with
Dr. Holly Wondertainment, an email to Fritz
from the Head of the Global Occult Coalition
congratulated the Administrator for an exciting
addition to the game in the form of Dr. Mann
tracking the GOI’s leaders.
Some, such as the leader of the Church of
the Broken God, contacted Fritz to express
their displeasure at including the risk of
being murdered by Mann. They claimed that
introducing such a rogue element to the game
after Fritz had already won felt like an indulgent
victory lap. In addition, one reported that
Holly Wondertainment had proclaimed dying
to be ‘unpleasant’ when she had woken
up after Mann had seemingly killed her. In
trying to uncover the truth about this sinister
game, Mann had found himself an unwilling
participant.
It appeared that the Administrator and the
GOI leaders were immortal, and while they
could be temporarily killed like Dr Wondertainment,
it wasn’t exactly an enjoyable experience.
Some GOI leaders even theorized that Fritz
introduced Mann to their game as a way of
eliminating them or their organizations. However,
Mann had no desire to kill any of them, apart
from Fritz himself, the leader of the entire
game. In his notes, Mann urges his O5-1 successor
to share the SCP-5555 file with the other
members of the O5 Council, to spread awareness
of the danger that Fritz, his various conspirators,
and their game poses.
Traveling to England, Mann attempted to obtain
Fritz’s location from Robert Bumaro, High
Priest of the Church of the Broken God. However,
he found himself trapped by Bumaro and Herman
Fuller, head of another Group of Interest,
the Anomalous Circus. Fuller knew that Mann
had worked alongside Fritz for years, and
could prove useful for the next round of the
game, while Bumaro told him to simply kill
Dr Mann, stating he “wasn’t worth dying
again”. However, Fritz appeared shortly
after to take Mann into custody, threatening
to kill his associates Bumaro and Fuller if
they didn’t release Dr Mann. While Bumaro
appeared more afraid of the dying process,
Fuller refused to relent, resulting in an
exchange of gunfire.
Fritz dragged the injured Mann away, patched
up his wounds and left him in a safehouse
with clean clothes, bathroom facilities and
a note explaining what had happened. Fritz’s
note told Mann that he’d left him a plane
ticket to Toronto, encouraging him to travel
there and take out The Critic, head of Are
We Cool Yet?, one of Fritz’s fellow conspirators.
The Administrator also left another updated
version of the SCP-5555 file, this time detailing
not SCPs that had been replaced, but members
of Foundation Staff.
It also stated that O5-2 to O5-13 were all
dead at Fritz’s hand, leaving only Dr Mann,
O5-1, as Fritz felt they’d “bonded.”
Reassuring the other leaders that he wasn’t
acting against them, Fritz explained through
emails that he had shaped Mann into the perfect
element for their game. Mann departed for
Toronto, assaulting The Critic in an effort
to gain more information, while also simultaneously
carrying out Fritz’s wishes. Dr Everett
Mann, for his part, continued to carry out
Fritz’s dirty work, tracking the various
GOI leaders and replaced Foundation Staff,
determined to topple Fritz and his game once
and for all.
Come the start of the new game, Fritz and
all his associates had switched roles with
each other. The Administrator of the Foundation
took on the role of Dr. Wondertainment. Dr.
Wondertainment became the Prophet of Mekhane,
a representative of the Church of the Broken
God. The role of the Global Occult Coalition’s
D. C. al Fine became Jude Kriyot, a member
of the mischievous “Gamers Against Weed”
group of interest. This new iteration of the
game also assigned Dr Mann the role of “Nobody.”
His win conditions for the game were to kill
all the others, having himself been made one
of them – an immortal – by Fritz. Assembling
his notes for the future O5 Council, Mann
set out on his hunt for Fritz, carrying with
him a relentless grudge and signing off with
a single item on a to-do list: “Kill Fritz.”
The story of SCP-5555, and the ongoing game
that it relates to perhaps explains why we
bury our dead. Sometimes uncovering them can
reveal secrets that should never see the light
of day. Some secrets, much like the dead,
are best left buried.
Next, why not check out “SCP - 087 - The
Stairwell” and “SCP - 096 - The Shy Guy”
for more anomalous tellings and explanations
of the SCP Foundation from SCP Explained!